I've been going getting into sort of a
debate on Twitter that I actually think
it's irresponsible to tell men to get
married in 2023 I think it's
irresponsible um I think if you're going
to tell men to get married you need to
warn them of the risk and the risk is it
doesn't matter who you marry it doesn't
matter how great of a of a man that you
are if a woman feels like leaving
unfortunately the government and the
state will back her up and even a good
Christian woman who prays can get the
wrong group of friends start watching
the wrong Media or just feel a certain
way and the state will legally allow her
to bankrupt you to take your children
and to falsely accuse you of abuse and
rape and that is the risk for a lot of
men and that is a death sentence to a
lot of men